it's like my favorite community of all
time is a guy named patrice o'neill who
like spent some time here actually okay
in in england i think he spent like a
few years even in england like really
kind of built himself up yeah but um oh
you must have
that's where he got good yeah so did
jay-z yeah so did bob marley did jay
really live here yeah i think he was
here for a little bit no no way is that
why he grew this stupid hair he has now
relax did he learn to ride a jet ski
with a helmet
yeah
so the um
patrice like he would do it not a
different show every time it would be
the same bits yeah but like his essence
was unique every time and he was
reacting to what was happening every
time so like i saw the bits more than
once but like he was real in between the
bits
you know what i mean it didn't feel like
he went up there and just pressed play
yeah yeah and i think that's where you
lose people cause some people i imagine
come for like the moments in between the
written jokes yeah yeah oh yeah yeah you
know yeah that's gonna make it different
every night like when we play live
that's why i like playing like live with
a band and stuff there's always
you know it's the same song but it's
different every different energy
and then sometimes you hear something
that the bass player done that he didn't
do yesterday and you look okay
no one recognizes it but you're like oh
yeah
you're like really jamming it's almost
like jazz in a way like there's some
improv with the tracks a little bit yeah
there's some yeah some improv with the
tracks you know yeah within right yeah
within really how many people will tour
like in the band and everything oh man
um
it's
max it there's like yeah there was a lot
of people when i done right level it was
like
and what other elements are you adding
to that live show that make it different
and discernible from other uh like grime
and hip-hop shows um
like probably
like the amount of the amount of players
right yeah the amount of players that we
had like um we've got a brass section
fire um street section yeah that
literally with hip-hop makes a
difference yeah yeah crazy especially
with him live instruments are so scary
because i saw i think james
[Music]
done it but what made me want to play
royal labor hall was i supported jay-z
at roy labo hall oh wow and he had the
orchestra
you know i mean wait did they did they
use their [ __ ] when you came right
home did they know you were coming out
um
they
some people probably knew i was coming
out yeah but i supported he meant like
he was the opener for him yeah and what
what is it
yeah did they lose their [ __ ] mind
yeah it was smart it was good yeah yeah
it was like as many kano fans in theirs
no no no at that time that yeah that was
like
2007. wow that was but you know what is
it 2004 or five you played 2005 my album
come out yeah my first album come out
and i've done that 2007 so yeah a lot of
his audience
would have known me yeah yeah and how
did you get that look
um
i can't remember i can't remember but
he's been yeah he's like
he said some nice you know words before
like he knew this stuff and all that
kind of [ __ ] and you guys like hung out
afterwards at all like just seeing each
other in the back did you watch him
cheat on his wife or was that your girl
he has a whole album talking about it
yeah
he didn't cheat bro
what's the apple for that
make some money dude that's a problem
they're not artists art it's just called
commerce that's commerce i wanted to
give you the time
that was a nice finesse though we got to
give them credit on that like if you're
gonna get cheated on make like tens of
millions of dollars yeah yeah yeah
i think most girls would be okay with
that well
tens of millions if they got it
yeah yeah but i'm so curious
what did he say to you are you allowed
to share
what did he say to me
yeah um i can't remember
but when i said he said no he said some
stuff like just in on the radio or
whatever it was yeah i just heard and
was like oh he's [ __ ] a bit whatever
um
yeah and i saw him at another show we i
was on the gorillaz album and we toured
without madison square garden oh wait
yeah well i i was just doing like two
songs yeah yeah but gorilla's obviously
a massive massive band we'd done a whole
american tour
um and he came to watch the show wow and
uh yeah he i remember
he was like side stage and i was about
to go up but it's the [ __ ] scariest
thing in the world like you're about to
step up the steps and you know
yeah this is crazy did you deliver
hey
[ __ ] to kevin hart kevin hart was doing
like barclays or something like that and
jay came to see him and jay was like how
does it feel and kevin hart was like man
it's crazy i never thought i'd sell out
barclays it's just a great feeling and
jay goes no how does it feel that i came
to see me